hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
concluded with the winner of the Iron
Throne begin well no one thanks to
drogon but the new seat of power in
Westeros is one that rolls with tree
wizard and awkward party guests bran the
broken replacing the wheel that Daenerys
broke with a set of wheels of his own
let us take Willis ride and breakdown
this finale episode with an in-depth
scene-by-scene analysis putting out all
the miserable callbacks to the 70s some
of the episodes hidden secrets and the
visuals and the music and how this show
adapted from George RR Martin's books
ended with subtle parallels to Martin's
big inspiration jr. RR Tolkien's Lord of
the Rings and really put the deeper
meaning of all this is like does Branch
winning mean I should be nicer to trees
I would be nicer if they stop laughing
at me
shut up trees let us start this deep
dive at the opening scene in which
Tyrion Lannister silently surveys the
ruins of King's Landing destroyed by
Daenerys a war criminal it is dark times
and the first element of this dark
nightmare that Tyrion notices are
falling snowflakes
despite Arya defeating the night King
and the Battle of Winterfell winter is
still coming now arriving and heavy
snowfall that blankets this destruction
further burying the dead and mixing
ominously with the drifting ash of the
city's remains snowfall on Game of
Thrones has always represented coming
death in darkness but now the element is
reassigned from the White Walkers to the
true arch villain of the series Daenerys
Targaryen as long as she breathes
Westeros remains under the threat of a
long night Tyrians eyes drop to the
carnage on the ground a little girl a
naked burn victim limping away
helplessly evoking the napalm victims of
the Vietnam War
another soldier sits in the rubble and
sobs into his hands and of course the
charred horse toy of the girl Arya tried
to save this young victim reminds us of
Shireen Baratheon terrible fates and for
Davos and the others a haunting sign of
the danger at the innocent face under
Danny's rule
Tyrion goes ahead alone Pasi a cracked
Bell one of the many bells that he hoped
would signal surrender but went not only
ignored by Daenerys weaponized when
drogon collapsed this bell tower onto
Arya Tyrion gazes up at what is left of
the red keep with the big change to its
skyline being the missing Tower
of the hand which was demolished in the
battle it reflects how Daenerys his
actions have made it literally
impossible for Tyrion to serve as her
hand John tries to stop grey worm from
executing Lannister POWs Zane gray WA
awkward John grey worm actually goes by
his original Valyrian name now torgo
nudho Jon should have remembered
Daenerys calling him that last episode
and later you'll notice their Davos
actually tries to correct this mistake
total included am I saying that properly
Tyrion passes over the mat floor
courtyard the past battle fissured this
map right down the middle of the
continent while shadowing the North's
future as an independent Kingdom but
before I continue thank you to raid
shadow legends or sponsoring this
episode
raid is the brand new free-to-play
mobile RPG with the most amazing
storyline awesome 3d graphics giant boss
fights PvP battles and hundreds of
champions to collect and customize like
I never expected to get this kind of
level of performance out of a mobile
game just look how crazy the level of
detail is on all these champions this
fellow's got some nipple rings you can
zoom and enhance all the way in on those
babies youch
and special announcement read shadow
legends special tournament is happening
globally right now you can compete with
me and millions of other players in a
massive arena tournament for crazy
in-game prizes and even physical prizes
that winners will get delivered straight
to their doorsteps
this is absolutely the best time to join
the action just go down to the
description and download raid only
through our link to get 50,000 silver
immediately plus a free epic champion as
the new player program and he'll also
automatically enter the special launch
tournament right away so see you there
okay back to Tyrion here he picks up a
torch and descends the tunnels and the
red keep echoing the torch lit escaped
the Jaime led him to in season 4 but
sadly Tyrion could not repay the favor
as he uncovers Jaime's golden hand and
Cersei space finally composed the Ramin
Djawadi breaks the silence with this
music
[Music]
this is the Lannister victory song the
rains of castamere the lyrics described
their father Thailand's brutal massacre
of house reyne Indian house rains
bloodline permanently but here the music
scores the end of House Lannister at
least the bloodline through Cersei and
Jaime Tyrion is devastated and later
when he resigns by tossing his hand to
the Queen pin it's almost as if he's
slapping Daenerys in the face with the
golden hand of his brother that she
killed
Arya and John witnessed the unsullied in
Dothraki celebration with a massive
Targaryen banner now draping the red key
now the red cape was built by Daenerys
his ancestors it's really a home that
belongs to her and reclaiming it like
this reflects John reclaiming Winterfell
with the white stark banners after the
Battle of the bastards but this victory
feels far more ominous Danny and drogon
arrive with a perfectly lined up shot of
Daenerys with dragons wings spreading
out from behind her making it look as
though the wings are her own this
metamorphosis invokes Daenerys his
father the Mad King who would like
Daenerys his brother Viserys would
threaten to physically transform into a
dragon and burn his enemies another
example of how Dany has become the ruler
that her father was Danny's speech to
her troops gives us a glimpse of what
rule under her would look like and it is
fully she begins by address saying of
all people the Dothraki
shefket either these dogs get an email
okay good on you she could be moti
shapka at the beasts oh come on again
buddy
Dany is calling back to the moment she
fired up her blood riders in season six
but by opening her speech with a shout
out to the most uncivilized pillagers of
ranks Daenerys is suggesting that
chaotic violence will be a major feature
of life with Danny Danny also makes grey
worm her new master of war which is kind
of bad sign because the position of
Master of War is new Cersei invented it
when she reorganized a small council
after Tywin's death as an attempt to
consolidate power and win over uncle
Kevan it would please the King if you
would serve as his master of war I did
not return to the capital to serve as
your puppet
so Daenerys is keeping the more
dangerous aspects of Circe's legacy
intact
Daenerys didn't free anyone from the
grip of a tyrant she just replaced
Cersei with a worse tyrant and as she
addresses the general on Sully
their formation frame sir as an
authoritarian dictator kind of the way
Hitler Mussolini would address their
army formations notice Mountaineers
calls them liberators which echoes the
Bush administration talking points
during the US invasion of Iraq
remember Dick Cheney promised the
Americans would be greeted as liberators
a statement it was later brought up by
critics of the invasion remember these
are the same showrunners who used a
dummy head of George W Bush in the
background of season one on a pike they
said it wasn't a political statement
they later apologized but however he has
slice said the anti-war themes are very
present in this episode and here in the
judgment of Daenerys hawkish sentiment
rewards to the unsullied are in valyrian
which Jon doesn't speak one of the many
nothings he knows he's just really
getting the dictator vibes from her tone
and body language but his head does turn
when Daenerys brings up Winterfell hen
vanes better value about Gordon not
Winterfell led by Sansa poses a threat
to Daenerys as does Dorne which is a
kingdom that historically the Targaryen
struggled to conquer Tyrion does speak
some valerian even though he thinks the
word for rusty is word for nostril no
Valyrian Mila Louisa but his head does
turn when she brings up his home city of
Lannisport
hey dog that lame yacht Ana's
interesting that she brings up carved
the Esso city that she left in season 2
because it reminds us of the promise
that she made to Qarth city leaders the
13 we will take back what was stolen
from me and destroy those who wronged me
we will lay waste to armies and burn
cities to the ground as Tyrion is
arrested after his resignation John and
Danny's eyes meet with some choice music
here
[Music]
it's a minor key version of their love
theme the dragon and the wolf except now
the cello strings moans sadly as if
mourning the death of their relationship
arias sneaky sneaks behind John making
this the third time she got the drop on
Kings this season and she warns him
about Danny no no I can't know that I
see what she's echoing her words to
Gendry earlier this season I know dad
he's got many faces one of those faces
of death was the night king and now Aria
is saying that the new face of death is
Daenerys John visits Tyrion who says so
is the knife off to death not that I've
seen Tyrion is recalling that John
freaking resurrected and John's response
is what he told lady Melisandre what did
you see there was nothing at all
by bringing this up here this show
clearly wants us to remember that Jon
Snow was resurrected by the Lord of
Light they don't want us to forget it as
some random never explained thing that
just happened seasons ago so the folks
were complaining that John was
resurrected for no reason and that
prophecies were ignored hold onto those
butts John and Tyrion debate over the
morality and motivation behind Danny's
war crimes and Tyrion assesses his own
record I strangled my lover I shot my
own father with a crossbow this is a
confession by Tyrion for killing Shaye
and Tywin he's a doomed man making peace
with the gods before his execution
remember Jaime actually made these same
kind of a confession to Brienne before
heading off to his death I pushed a boy
out of town and OH
crippled him for life I strangled my
cousin with my own hands
but Syrian is comparing his worst deeds
to Daenerys she liberated the people of
slavers Bay she liberated the people of
King's Landing he'll go on liberating
and to the people of the world her free
periods argument reflects the famous
words of German pastor Martin niemoller
the passage reflecting how to moderate
Germans during World War two were
bystanders excusing the rise of fascism
in Germany first they came for the
socialists and I did not speak out
because I was not a socialist then they
came for the trade unionist but I did
not speak out because I was not a trade
unionist then they came for the Jews and
I did not speak out because I was not a
Jew then they came for me and there was
no one left to speak for me tear
is now that speaker he did not speak out
against Authority until it was too late
he's now facing the same fiery
liberation that Danny's other victims
have tyrion tells John that love is more
powerful than reason and John responds
of his the death duty he's quoting
maester aemon at the wall in season one
love in that moment Eamon foreshadowed
to John be exact choice that he now
faces sooner or later in every man's
life there comes a day when it is not
easy a day when he must choose in that
moment season one John was struggling
with a bloody transfer of power down in
King's Landing and an unjust arrest of
Ned Stark but he surrendered his love
for family killing the boy inside him to
let the man be born which he does again
in this episode after a bloody transfer
of power in King's Landing and an unjust
arrest he reaffirms his Night's Watch
vows he does his duty to kill that which
she loves and ultimately this episode he
returns to take the black just like a
man once did he was rightful heir to the
Iron Throne as well but he stepped aside
to allow a younger family member to take
his place
Tyrion ends a debate with this
interesting question who is more
dangerous than the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne this finale episodes title
is the Iron Throne and here Tyrion is
sardonically hinting at the deeper theme
the evil of right that those who believe
that they have the right to power that
they deserve power and are within grasp
of that power are the most vulnerable to
moral corruption and that they become
the most desperate and the most violent
and their attempt to take that power in
this regard Game of Thrones is
thematically linking its iconic image
the Iron Throne with the equivalent in
the Lord of the Rings the Ring of Power
just like the Iron Throne the Ring of
Power is a man-made treasure forged in
fire that corrupts anyone who occupies
it will see this comparison play out
throughout the final episode John
marches to the red keep blocked by
drogon rising up in the snow guarding
the Queen a wide shot of Jon facing
dragons massive head bret presents his
vivid scale jon is a classic dragon
slayer hero for mythology like Beowulf
but the shot actually mirrors the wide
shot of Tyrion facing the skull of
balerion the dread below earlier it's a
sign that Jon has already made up his
mind poised to be Tyrians champion in
his trial by combat in this trial
against the dragon queen
Brown looks into Jon's soul similar to
the cryptic look that he gave John back
in the season premiere and he lets him
past surrendering now this is huge
drogon only trust John because John has
Targaryen blood if you think about that
makes John the only person in the world
right now with striking distance access
to Danny and the only one with the moral
cause to stop her had John not been
resurrected and not been a Targaryen no
one would be able to stop Daenerys from
plunging the world into darkness inside
the red keep Daenerys his approach to
the throne fulfills the imagery from her
permission in the house of the undying
in season two her damage to the walls in
the roof allows snow to drift in just as
it did in her vision and there's this
close-up of her hand reaching to the
throne except in that vision she pulled
away but now she touches it
that vision foretold Danny never fully
gaining the Iron Throne instead becoming
queen of the ashes and leaving that
behind in an afterlife with Drogo
similarly in the scene Daenerys will
return east with drogon the dragon named
after Drogo and her son will set in the
east the moment Dany touches the throne
this wave of catharsis hits earth
much like the drunk trance caused by the
Ring of Power when John appears behind
her she turns to meet him but her eyes
for a moment cling to the throne as if
she can't break away from her precious
Danny tells the story about learning a
throne was made from a thousand swords
and she laughed that as a girl she could
only count to 20 but John angrily cuts
her off because the same way a thousand
melted swords from Aegon's conquest was
hard for her to imagine a million melted
bodies of her conquests don't look like
anything to her either
John begs her to reconsider but Danny
just smiles and says it's not easy to
see something that's never been visible
Emilia Clarke plays this moment with
such conviction speaking as an idealist
asking for blind faith but her phrasing
also hints at her insanity preceding
hallucinations that do not exist echoing
the convictions of her Mad King father
John brings up others out there might
also believe that they know what's good
but Danny responds she's repeating the
choice words that Tyrion spoke to John
moments before about Sansa doesn't get
to choose no but you do and the choice
words that bran spoke to John in the
godswood
it's your choice it all goes back to the
choice that aim
foreshadow to John in season 1 John has
already made this choice he chose duty
to the Nights Watch duty to his family
by telling them he's half Targaryen duty
to Tyrion by confronting Daenerys right
now John kisses Dany and he stabs her
repeating Jaime Lannister's history as a
Kingslayer and now John is the queen
Slayer saving the realm from a mad
Targaryen monarch one could interpret
this murder as John fulfilling the
prophecy of azor Ahai Dany in a sense is
the sacrificial missa missa figure the
flaming swords of the Iron Throne as
Lightbringer and Daenerys is death and
Dragons departure is an away John
vanquishing darkness from this world
Daenerys his final breaths are tragic
john cradles her body with her head
craned back still staring at the iron
throne the way Gollum died cleaned to
his precious Emilia Clarke said that in
her final moment she included a hint of
vulnerability the little girl that we
met in season 1 drug on arrives sadly
nuggie and Dany like Simba an undead
Mufasa and rather than torching John he
took horses the iron throne dragons are
magical creatures so perhaps he has the
cosmic wisdom to recognize the true
source of evil among them the throne was
forged by dragon fire from a gods dragon
balerion and now the throne is undone by
drogon with the swords melting down into
indistinguishable lava just as the Ring
of Power was this throne was the symbol
that Aegon used to bind the Seven
Kingdoms together causing them to war
against each other over and over again
throughout the ages in pursuit of this
throne so its destruction signals the
end of the game of Thrones drogon takes
Dany and departs signaling also the end
of magic in Westeros this episode marks
this dramatic climax with a fade to
black similar to the fades to black that
Peter Jackson used in Return of the King
after the rings destruction so this
primary conflict has come to an end
and everything that follows is a sort of
epilogue that resets the game board so
then a few weeks later Tyrion is brought
to the King's Landing dragon pit to face
the council returning them all to the
same location in last season's finale
the roll call includes same while Tarly
is water-bottle another unnamed High
Lord may be Howland Reed some are
suggesting it could be theirs ed Murtagh
Lee from the Riverlands Arya bran and
Sansa Brienne Davos his water bottle
and ginjury now lord of storms end then
two more unnamed Lords may be from the
reach or the rack yar a Greyjoy the new
Prince of Dorne and then from the Vale
sweet Robin grown up mama's milk done
his body good Lord Royce and another
unknown arya threatens Yara probably
hates her for putting the letters Arry
and a in the wrong order say another
word about killing my brother and I'll
cut your throat
it's answer shuts down her uncle ed
murrow stood he said these stark sisters
are setting the table for the younger
generation to take over and fix the
problems of the previous generation
Sansa reminds grey worm that her
northern forces have surrounded King's
Landing which could explain why only the
north is granted independence in the
scene places like the Iron Islands and
Doran might not have the military might
to put pressure on the crown like this
Sam proposes that future leaders of
Westeros be elected democratically to
get the big belly laugh from these
elitist Lords now it is a little odd
that Yara laughs this off - since the
Ironborn do traditionally select new
leaders with a fairly democratic process
called the king's moot although to be
honest the Ironborn also consider
themselves much stronger than a land
dwellers and will probably look down on
some ocean from flea bottom having any
say and who rules it for them so instead
the council adopts an oligarchical
system of rule by the few with these
elite representatives from across the
kingdom selecting the ruler in the real
world the ancient Greeks had an Oleg our
key system that they eventually balanced
with a more randomized democratic
systems I don't know maybe we can look
at this collapse of bloodline dynasties
as a sort of baby step in the right
direction or maybe considering that
America is essentially a financial
oligarchy these days step in a very dark
timeline
Tyrion makes a case for who he wants a
new ruler to be there's nothing in the
world more powerful than a good story
and who has a better story than brand
the broken now you might not agree that
bran has the best story I mean Ari has
been pretty fun to watch but Tyrion is
right that bran is the best choice bran
is impartial not prone to rage or
violence pride or jealousy or lust Rand
isn't one to anything other than maybe
sunlight in a pot of fresh soil and the
council selecting brand parallels the
fellowship and a ring selecting Frodo
Baggins to carry the burden of the Ring
of Power
the humble figure who least once power
is the safest hands in which to rest
that power and their best chance at
lasting peace and by naming him bran the
broke
Tyrion isn't just being a jerk he's
alluding to the wheel that Daenerys
aimed to break and the breaking of the
old system and yes the breaking up of
the continent into six kingdoms in the
North since in brans eyes that would
lead to a more lasting peace between
them and let's remember the North was
historically independent only ever
annexed by Aegon the conquerer but now
that the Targaryen czar finished and the
dragons are gone it makes sense that the
north be restored to its longtime
independence and with the first episode
of the series ending with brands iconic
fall the fall that broke him his rise
here is a mere reflection of that fall
an ascendancy to king bran the broken
tyrion alludes to the words of
three-eyed Raven he knew he'd never walk
again so he learned to fly you'll never
walk again
but you will fly this ascent is scored
with the main game of Thrones theme
music but with each measure changing key
to scale up and up and up all right
brands responses of course a head
scratcher
why do you think I came all this way so
this implies that brand knew that this
was his destiny and this is all
according to his plan in season six
brand did foresee many future events the
explosion of wildfire in King's Landing
bringing Cersei to throne that shadow of
drogon over King's Landing bringing Dany
to the throne he gave Arya the Valyrian
steel dagger which she would later used
to kill the night king and he and Sam
determined that John was the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne and bran and
power Jon to share this information so
that it would unravel his relationship
with Danny and create a power vacuum
but while brand saw all of this I don't
think he necessarily wanted it all to
happen the people of King's Landing
Burnie and John killing Danny I mean
maybe he's a little dirty bastard but I
don't think it was really his plan just
the predestined plan that bran was now
following like a script remember Hodor
had always said Hodor before bran was
even born by working in - Hodor through
time brand fulfill the destiny that was
already written so similarly bran played
the role that was already written for
him a role that would one day nice for
him lead him to a crown bran selects
Tyrion as his hand which is really a
kind of punishment he's made many
terrible mistakes he's going to spend
the rest of his life fixing them Tirion
stuck back in this job reminds us of the
punishment it was at the beginning of
the series what's the line
the king and the hand wipes this hand I
assume will like trim hedges and spray
pesticide this finale also restores
season 1 punishment with the solution
for Jon Snow with searing ordering him
to join the Nights Watch just like Ned
Stark was originally going to do before
Joffrey chopped his head off John asks I
still nights watch the world always need
a hostage and broken men even know White
Walkers appear to be destroyed the
Nights Watch must remain to protect the
realm against any unknown threats in the
future because yeah that night remains
dark and full of terrors in Tyrion is
suggesting that will live on as a kind
of penal colony its words actually echo
is lying back in season 1 I've attended
a spot in my heart those bastards and
broken things and as we will see in
these final moments cripples bastards
and broken things do indeed inherit this
world grey worm says the unsullied will
sail to the Isle of not Natha isthmus
Sunday's homeland which grey worm
promised to take her back in episode 2
of the season no I'd like to see the
beaches again it sounds like grey worms
bringing back Masson days remains to
bury their and maybe the unsullied will
stick around in the Summer Isles to
protect the people of North and the
other islands from being taken as slaves
from the slavers of Essos the unsullied
did begin the series of slaves it makes
sense that that would be their future
John leaves with the Nights Watch his
hair back to its awesome shaggy look
from his brotherhood days he bids
farewell to Sansa Arya and bran from the
port similar to Frodo saying goodbye to
his three Hobbit friends when he sailed
away with Bilbo in the elves at the end
of Return of the King
but really it's arias epilogue that's
more in line with Frodo's she tells John
that she is actually sailing away what's
west of Westeros Arya is referencing her
scene with lady crane back in season 6
the first times she thought about a
future beyond her conflicts as was his
east in Westeros is West but was west of
Westeros I don't know nobody does so
they're all the maps to the edge of the
world maybe I'd like to see that and by
chasing this kind of dream R is actually
parallel in the ancient figure Alyssa
Farman from George RR Martin's fire and
blood Alyssa was an explorer who sailed
west of Westeros across the sunset sea
on her ship called Sunchaser she
actually found three islands which she
named Aegon
Rhaenys and Visenya and she continued
sailing west but she was never seen
again
except her ship the Sun chaser was
claimed to have been seen in the harbor
of a shy in the Far East
perhaps confirming that the world of
Westeros is round as Jorge Ramon says it
is and that may be ELISA circumnavigated
it aria could be following in her
footsteps Brienne of Tarth now Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard flips
through the book of brothers that's the
document that tracks the life and
accomplishments of all the Knights who
served on the Kingsguard Jaime actually
pointed this out to Brienne in season
four the duty of the Lord Commander to
fill those pages there's still room left
in mine Brianna's flip passed the pages
of Sir Arthur Dayne the legendary Knight
Ned Stark fought and killed outside the
Tower of joy and Barristan Selmy what
she finds Jaime's sadly pathetic blank
pages that just kind of talked about him
like a slain book remember this is the
location that Jaime started to rewrite
his new destiny the place that he gave
Brienne his sword which she named
Oathkeeper and now that same sword rests
on the table before her she writes this
heroic account of Jaime's defense
against Danny throughout season seven
and his fighting alongside them in the
Battle of Winterfell and she finishes it
with died protecting his queen so that
instead of being remembered as the
Kingslayer Jaime Lannister will be
remembered as a knight who did his duty
even if that Queen he was protecting was
like toxic and like wrong for him sorry
it's gonna take me a while to get over
Jaime in the small council chamber
Tyrion straightens the chairs
I like the clutter that this room was an
earlier Tyrion is cleaning up his
mistakes remember when he was handed a
king in season 2 he played political
games of the small Council he's shrunken
member by member to consolidate power
but now he takes it seriously he wants
it to function properly Davos is a new
master of ships run master of coin Sam
the new grand maester he'll notice that
sam has two links on his chain implying
mastery of two subjects perhaps a
history may be master of medicine given
his expertise curing greyscale he
presents Tyrion with this new aptly
named historical text a Song of Ice and
Fire
acht mystery Bros history of the walls
following the death of King Robert
remember archmaester ebro's was jim
broadbent character of season 7 he told
Sam about this new history book he's
working on you didn't like the title
what would you call it then possibly
something a bit more poetic I guess it
makes sense that Sam's new poetic title
is exactly what george RR martin calls
this book series but it Evo
the ace of the battles up north the fire
of the battles down south as well as of
course the ice and the fire reflected in
John and Daenerys Tyrion is not
mentioned in his book but similar to his
brother Jaime the pages of Tyrion story
remained blank perhaps this just means
that Tyrians most significant
contributions to history are yet to be
written
Brienne inserter Podrick enter with King
brand but notices some vacant positions
we appear to be missing a master of
whisperers and a master of laws and a
master of wool and a master of gardening
how will I survive really the lack of
any rush to fill those spots suggests
that bran and Tyrion Earl is focused on
war on prosecution on espionage then
they are with rebuilding the
infrastructure the economy and health of
Westeros which is a really good sign
bran leaves the management of the
kingdom to them as he prepares to search
for drogon perhaps hinting at a future
for brand of war gain inside a dragon
Davos and bran bicker assume the won't
be normal coin any more you master of
grammar now to Thomas's correction as a
habit that he picked up from serving
Stannis Baratheon and it's foolish
fingernails to clean fewer less enemies
for us
whew what an Tyrion brings up his
experience with the Casterly Rock sewers
- Sam who says the autumn a sister has
done some research on this subject yeah
Sam is referring to his experience
clean-out maester in season seven in the
Citadel this scene really ends like the
final shot of a sitcom with Tyrion and
teasing his famous joke I once brought a
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel
and he doesn't tell us the punchline
Tyrion has set up this same joke twice
before once during his trial in the
Eyrie another while trying to make some
small talk with Masson day and grey worm
really the best pitch for the punchline
I could find online and I'm sorry I
couldn't find the source of this I won't
support a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel the madam says what's with the
honeycomb I say I wish for a house fit
for a queen and she asks what about the
jackass and I tell her I wish for the
finest ass in Westeros so I wish to work
that hangs below my knees and it came
true so I came to this brothel madam
says that's not so bad and I say yes but
I used to be six foot three
Jon Snow returns to Castle black finding
tormund who foreshadowed that Jon would
return to the north the last time they
saw each other you've got to Nathania
the real off the final montage centers
around John Sansa and Arya each of them
in a close-up as they ready themselves
John with Longclaw
Oreo with her dagger Sansa dressing and
fine embroidery echoing her opening
moments on the series to cheat
impressive embroidery in Winterfell her
dress here has a pattern with red
weirwood tree leaves looks awesome these
intercutting images reflect the opening
of the season six finale which similarly
showed characters dressing up for the
day but it was set to the music of light
of the seven this montage is scored by
new music this track is titled the last
of the Starks and it blends light motifs
from the House Stark theme and the main
game of Thrones title music
[Music]
so the way that light is 7 was Circe's
great victory moment this montage is a
victory for House Stark finally on top
after their long suffering throughout
the series the editing syncs up the
movement of these three figures
reminding us of the northern saying
about moving and survival keep moving so
these three northerners success at
stayin moving has kept them alive and so
they in this series in a March onward
Game of Thrones ends really with the map
expanding and all four compass headings
beyond Westeros John heads north Arya
heads west drogon and Dany head east in
grey worm head south Sansa is crowned
queen and turn off the first ruler of a
North that's actually recognized by the
Westeros crown in over a thousand years
very much deserve Arya heads out on a
ship that also bears the sigils of House
Stark the direwolf on the sails and
carved into the bow of the ship she
sails west to channeling great explorers
like Alyssa farmen and real world
Circumnavigators like Ferdinand Magellan
and Amelia Earhart her final image shows
her gazing off at the horizon just like
the last time she sailed away from
Westeros east to Braavos the final shot
of season 4 now she's heading west into
the sunset like these start sisters John
also reimburses his direwolf sigil a
literal direwolf ghost giving the good
boy a good boy Pat and he leads the wild
lanes north of the wall in a final scene
that echoes the very first cold open
imagery of the pilot episode shot
Prashad including the first shot of the
series of the gate rising and the wide
shot of the horses heading out north of
the wall except now in this final scene
there are some key differences the first
episodes expedition was essentially a
crime scene investigation hinting that a
winter coming a winter that would take
wildling families and children with it
but now the wild lien families marched
north with their children the icy threat
has been defeated there's even a tiny
green plant rising from the snow hey a
friend for king branch it's a nod to the
title for George RR Martin's final book
of the series a dream of spring and an
elemental counterpoint to the
snow-covered death of the opening
imagery of this episode Jon's future is
a mystery will he stay with wildlings up
north or is he just leading them on an
expedition considering his status as a
resurrected champion of the Lord of
Light could he follow in the footsteps
of the night's king from the books not
the night king from the show but the
legendary Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch who is half alive half too
fell in love with a woman with white
skin and blue eyes it's fun to
hypothesize about these mysteries but
really if you look at this final imagery
it's filled with peace with life hope a
dream of spring John is one of many
supernatural forces who are now leaving
Westeros behind if you think about it
Arya Stark is really a ninja assassin
pulling off impossible feats but her
power is too much for the continent to
handle so she moves on Brogan the dragon
flies off in the opposite direction from
arya and john as the one resurrected
person the person who seems to plot
armor that defies all kinds of death
he's leaving north these forces
departing means peace and Westeros can
finally last and with the evil
represented by the Iron Throne finally
destroyed the bloody Game of Thrones can
end comment down below with your
thoughts on this game of Thrones final
episode and thank you to all of you for
appreciating this show with me every
week it has brought so much joy into my
life but we still have more Game of
Thrones analysis coming your way and
coverage of the upcoming prequel series
whenever that happens plus here at new
rock stars deep dives into everything
you love so subscribe to new rock stars
on YouTube subscribe to our podcast to
mean Westeros weekly follow me on
instagram and twitter at EI vas and
thank you for joining me and as much as
I love the final shots being scored by
Roman Jawad E's new Song of Ice and Fire
theme I wouldn't mind it if Jon Snow
walked off to dire straits walk of life
[Music]